BEIJG E CHINE A IS IN A O PUSH
INIP.
>> RorUSSIA'S VLADIM PUTIN RPET
FOS,CHINESE PRESENEE
SE OF ETINGS IMOSKEPTICISM THATI
UK TE N THE PEACD BY CHINA ARE
WITH RUSSIS AND CAN
BE TAKENTH A
THIS REANET OBSERVED IV ARE REA
ON T
MORE T ON
IN
ENERGY RCIESTERNTERN CH
SULI ELECTRONICS AND
AIRCRAFT AND PDIN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE U.S. LL
SHE ISN TO CHINA
THIS YEAR AN
SHARR  RSIE PROPOSAL
FOR UKIN A PLAINWOULFY
RUSSIA'S GRI OUP.
PUTIN .AT TO SEE
IT WET TERRIBLE EXAMPLE
FOR THE CHINESE SYSTEM.
AND RUSSI
COMIC HISTORY, BUT
THEIR SHARDVERSARIAL SHIP W
>> THIS IS A MAG
NV
SSIA THERE'S ISM ABOUBEIJING'
TI TV  SHOW,
THISY PUNDIT S ONLY ONE , CHINA
INTERESTS, PRO-CSEE FOREIGN POL
UTRL OSM.
BUESE STATE MEDIA IS IN ERDRIV
OF THECHA RELATIONSHIP ALL
POSITIVE COMMEORED SOCIAL NES C
CUSSIA FRIENDSHIP
A TIN, XS
STATESMAN THAT CALTERNATIVE TO
NEUTRALITY, BUALING NO TSIGN LI
PRICE.AT'S WHY THE SPEAK
TO SAY IT' THAT CHINA THE KINDFL
SECONDARJAKE. THATLD
>> SELINA WANGBEIJG.> JAPAN'S P
FUMIO CUE SHE ADA SURPRISE
TRE
TRIRTIME JAPE PRIME MINISTER
ANWITH
FIGHTING SINCE W WITN
CITY OF
KHARV. OF THISIT PR.
>> IT DOES, AND IT DOES NOT SEKU
THE SAME DAY SITING
THE PAME MINISTER
ENEMY, THE
CAPITAL  LAYINS IN BUCHERE
RIESF MASS
OF PEOPLE EXR EHIND THEIR BACKS
AFTER THN  TSKIRT KYI
JAPAN SIGNALG S COMMITMENT
TO UKRAINE.
LAST MONTH ID SO
$5.5 BILLION IN ASSISTAN
UKRAINIAN GOVERNME HAS
SAHAT IT SPEAKS OUST, AS I IT,
AGGRESSION INTO UKRAINE.HE MEAN
OW CLOSELY.
THE UKRAINIA
VOLODYMYR ZEKYY HAS COME OUTABF
BYIN ASAYING
SATIS THGHT  GOI
SAY THATWOULD SIMPLY
FREEZE THE CONFLICT AND ALLOSS T
N
HAS ITN
D THAT PROBAVOLVESSIG
TERRITORY, ANTS TO SHARE
THAT DIRECTLY WITH THE CHI
LEWE DON'TNO T TWO LE
>> AND I RUSSIA
ARE DIUTTHE DETAILS OF AN
ATTACK ITH
CAYI CALIB CRUISE
TH ATTACK? R SEEN , WHAT AOFCINT
AMATEUR VIDEO  AN EXPLOSION
LAST N.
SHIPMENT OF THESE CRUISE
CO DO HAVE
THE RUSSIANS
E KIND
ATTACK.
AS INJUREDTHEY HAVEN'T SAID ANY
IN MEANTIME, TONHTOUPLE OF
D ILKES ON E SOUTHERN UKRT CITY
OF ODESA, TH
THHE DOWN TWO OF
LAUNCHED BY RUSSIAN WAR PLAN